a little dinner
keep looking at all of that
if you want to take a screenshot we'll
have all the crap
all right that's fine thank you
is
all right the mayor is on her way so we
should be good to go
in about four minutes i'll do one last
mic
check mic check one two three
hey josh got a two-minute warning a
little more than usual
take this one this is fine i can't yeah
okay
i'll leave it here okay you want the
umbrella too yeah blocks
yes i get wet yeah
oh
you
all right mayor governor is on their way
the governor will go first
you gave it to me already i'm sorry
hold on i haven't edited
fire chief
thank you
okay
great
hello everyone thank you for joining us
again um we're gonna start the press
conference shortly
remember please hold your questions to
the end and we'll be addressing everyone
it's too much
thank you so much i'm debbie wasserman
schultz i represent florida's 23rd
congressional district which
includes surfside and this morning i've
had an opportunity not only to
participate in mayor levine cava's
briefing
uh intergovernmental briefing but to sit
down and talk with
our national experts from nist
which is the similar agency that that
reviews and comes in to decide whether a
full investigation will be necessary
for structural damage building collapses
they were investigators in 911 they were
best investigators
in a number of structural incidents
around the country
and are the best of the best when it
comes to making sure
that they do a complete and thorough
overview during a preliminary
investigation right now to determine
whether or not
they open a full investigation i mean
i'm not an expert but i would expect
that
it is natural that they would decide to
do that and their role
is to very forensically review
as the process of going through the
rubble
even during the search and rescue
process to help
make sure that evidence preserved which
they're working with the task force on
debris to do that
to make sure that even with the army
corps of engineers
that is embedded in their team to take a
look at some of the issues that have
arisen
anecdotally but you know the issues like
the questions around the structural
damage to the pool
that area that has been mentioned and
other different
points of of weakness they will
look through that preliminary
investigation and determine whether they
open a full investigation
and that is triggered when they get a
sense of
after their preliminary review of
whether or not any
decisions and and fact-finding that they
engage in
as a result of that investigation can
have longer term
implications and recommendations for how
we
change federal oversight federal law
related to building construction and
the kind of code enforcement decisions
that will have to be made on the ground
so it's really important and very
significant that they're here as early
as they have been
because getting them here embedded with
the the debris task force
making sure that they advise on how
evidence should be preserved
once law enforcement takes over will
give them a better chance
of answering the question that i know
i've been asked over and over we all
have been
you know okay how are we going to deal
with the long-term implications of this
did this only impact just this building
we have as we've said you know
structures like this
all the way up the coastline all the way
up the coastline of the united states
and
what nist will be able to help do is
they're a fact finding not a fault
finding agency
and a long-term investigation of theirs
would give us a chance
for me as a member of congress to be
able to
implement to adopt changes in federal
law that will help them make sure that
when structures are built
that something like this could never
have never happened again so i'll
continue to be engaged with our our very
seamless
local state and national leaders so that
we can make sure that we have
continue the whole of government
approach where there's no daylight
between any of us
thank you so much and thank you mayor
levine for all your work
thank you congresswoman and governor on
the sentence
quite a chance to meet with a number of
the urban search and rescue teams today
and as i have seen them of course over
over the last many days but they've been
going at it for over a hundred hours
straight
when there's danger they run towards it
they obviously shepherded a lot of
people to safety
initially and they have been every
minute of every day
uh since the building collapsed uh
trying to identify
survivors uh they're putting themselves
at risk in order to do that
not only because some you could have
additional collapse
you've had deep-seated fires that
they've had to fight it's been an
incredibly hazardous environment
and they've been on the scene non-stop
from the very beginning so i just want
to thank them for what they've done
we obviously have some other folks
throughout the state
that have been able to also come and
supplement but those teams here in south
florida
uh they're the best of the best and we
we had the israelis come in
and take a look and the israelis told
some of the families
what those miami-dade search and rescue
foot folks did is exactly
what we would have done exactly what
should have been done um and so i think
it's a testament you know our best in
the country here in south florida
some of the best in the world obviously
israel coming over they deserve
a lot of credit for putting themselves
out there and obviously
the search continues and it will not
stop
until there's a resolution so thank you
for that we're also working
in conjunction with fema as well as in
conjunction with
both local government and private
organizations to bring relief
services to the family members and that
involves relocation assistance it
involves things like mental health
counseling
and we have folks we beef that up here
on the ground
and what we want to do is working with
fema identify
all the families get them registered
face to face which fema is doing and is
doing a good job of
and be able to provide these services i
have the head of volunteer florida
is on the ground to help coordinate with
all the great volunteer organizations
the outpouring with the charitable
donations has been incredible
millions of dollars and i think there's
going to be millions of more so it's a
testament to this community
here in surf side as well as the greater
miami dade area and as well as florida
and the united states because people
from all across the country
have been involved in that so those uh
recovery efforts from the family
of helping them get back on their feet
helping them cope
uh with trauma that's going to be
ongoing and this is something that's
going to require community involvement
local government state government and
fema for for a while and we're in that
for the long haul
the final thing is of course rescue
number one
uh care for the people that have been
placed this place number two but we do
obviously need to identify why this
happened um i was able to meet with the
nist folks today
uh and uh they were created after 9 11.
they've done a handful of really
thorough investigations since their
creation
911 they did joplin missouri
from the uh tornadoes they're doing
hurricane maria
in puerto rico they did a rhode island
nightclub fire that happened almost 20
years ago
um and uh and so they've never done
just a straight building collapse that
wasn't involved with either
hazards or terrorism and so this is
going to be something that's important
it is something that's going to be very
thorough and is something that is not
going to happen
in a day or two this is going to take a
long time that's the time horizon they
work on
uh and i understand that what i've told
mayor burkhead and surfside as well as
mayor cava
because surfside has retained people to
look in
and then obviously miami-dade with the
state attorney they're doing an
investigation
i think those investigations may be able
to provide us with some information
maybe a little sooner than an ist
and i think that's important because if
there are things that need to be done at
the state level
you know we obviously would want to get
information you know as soon as possible
and so we pledge at the state if they
need support from engineers from experts
whatever we need whether it's surfside
miami-dade we're here to help
i think the people of florida want to
understand how could this happen
and then what can we do to to make sure
it doesn't happen again
and so we'll be working on that for the
long term but in the interim
thank you for everybody who's going
through that rubble thank you for being
on the front lines for us
um your work is uh very very important
and it's been very very selfless
thank you governor and now lieutenant
governor jeanette jones
thank you good morning i'll reiterate
what the governor said in spanish
is
a
[Music]
thank you lieutenant governor now
miami-dade county mayor danielle
here we are day five and the search and
rescue
were continued throughout the night you
know 24 7
the tireless work of our first
responders
these are truly the men and women who
have dedicated their lives to saving
lives
and this is what they live for to save
lives so they're out there with every
resource
that they need to ensure
that they can search this area they can
sweep the mound
with cameras with dogs with sonar
and additional heavy machinery that has
come in to start to clear away
the debris we are exploring all
possible avenues that they identify
and we're going to continue and work
ceaselessly to exhaust every possible
option in our search i repeat
the search and rescue operation
continues
as the governor and the congresswoman
said and
the lieutenant governor there is going
to be a thorough
and full investigation of what led
to this tragic event
we are going to get to the bottom of
what happened here
right now our top priority is search and
rescue
and find the people
and you can see we have a truly
unprecedented mobilization effort
underway
with the full resources of our local
state and federal government
on hand already for days already
and people coming in from around the
state and around the world
to assist us right here in surfside
i am so grateful to all of the leaders
and all of the teams and especially
those
who are up on the mound and putting
their own lives
at risk to find others
this morning we did recover another body
that brings the count to 10.
the total number of those accounted for
is now 135
and the total unaccounted 151.
our detectives are working in real time
right now to audit this list
we're receiving multiple calls still
from family
members about the same loved ones and
the information is coming from
various sources i want to stress as we
have from the beginning
these numbers are very fluid and they
will continue
to change i want to provide you as we
have done and will do
the best updates as soon as we have them
remembering that we've told the families
that are waiting that they will be the
first to hear
and they were the first to hear about
this temple
victim that we uncovered today
so we will continue to support all of
the families
and loved ones who are affected with
their mental health
their social service their physical
needs
they have professionals on site a full
gamut
in the family assistance center
the miami foundation one of those that
launched
the donation site is also on site to
assist
these families with the cash assistance
they need
to get on with their lives as well and
we know
that as was said millions have been
collected across these different
donation uh sites uh it's really quite
incredible so please
continue to pray for the families
continue to pray
for the search and rescue team the best
in the world
we have hundreds on backup we have the
people we need
we are continuing without stop
thank you and god bless
thank you madam mayor and now chief
financial officer and fire marshal give
me petrol
thank you good afternoon governor thank
you for your leadership through all this
uh you don't get a break hurricanes
pandemics
you name it this governor has been boots
on the ground he's been leading since
day one
uh mayor your staff uh amazing the folks
of miami-dade county the resilience that
they've provided
this is an international issue as we've
seen support come from the federal
international community i'm the state's
chief financial officer i'm also the
state fire marshal
also a citizen of the state of florida
proud to be here
with the urban search and rescue men and
women of task forces that are assigned
here
this is the largest ever deployment of
task force resources in the history
of the state of florida that's not a
hurricane the same a number of men and
women that are on the ground right now
is the same as that was deployed to
hurricane michael which is a 12-county
storm event
they're working around the clock they're
working 12 hours at a time
midnight to noon noon to midnight
they come from tallahassee they come
from orlando they come from tampa
they come from israel they come from
mexico they come from jacksonville they
come from fort myers
they come and they leave their families
to come and work around the clock
the reward is the life they save they
are making the efforts as we speak right
now and they don't stop
they hardly rest they come off for about
45 minutes they check their pulse
they check their o2 levels and they go
back to work because that's what they do
they work to save lives i've got the
honor to be here with them
and so proud of the efforts that are
taking place here i can't say enough for
the leadership
of kevin guthrie and florida department
of emergency management for fema
they have provided as uh as they know
the magnitude of this event this came
from a camp
and now we've created a city inside of a
city several blocks
and uh we appreciate all the patience
that the communities have had here in
the region
as we do the most amazing efforts
in the history of the state of florida
to save the lives at risk because of
this
terrible tragedy governor thank you for
your leadership
mayor
thank you now from the florida division
of emergency management kevin hey
good morning everyone kevin guthrie
florida division of emergency management
director
uh yesterday at about 4 15
yesterday afternoon mayor cava chief
kaminsky asked
for the assistance of a federal incident
support team
specifically related to urban search and
rescue uh
fema was in the room at the exact same
time the informal communication of that
request
happened in minutes so that was uh that
request was
sent out and mobilized and we have uh
followed up with the necessary paperwork
so again i think it's important for
everyone to understand that as soon as
maricava chief kaminsky director ramirez
need a resource we're sitting together
we're working together underneath the
leadership of the governor the
lieutenant governor
mayor cava and others to make sure that
that happens
instantly again congresswoman said there
is no daylight in between either one of
us
so i think that's important for everyone
to know i will say that we also are
mobilizing
today a florida dhsmv bus
to help people get id cards for those
that have been displaced
uh they need id cards driver's licenses
and things of that nature
those will be that bus will be deployed
today
should be here on site tomorrow thank
you
thank you director and now the surfside
man mayor
charles burkett
i just have a handful of things i want
to share with you
first was this morning i was at the site
and
i observed hundreds of
search and rescue people actively
using their hands digging out and doing
what they're here to do
i also observed the heavy equipment that
the governor
and the federal government have sent
down to us in action
lifting off huge slabs and moving them
away from the pile secondly i uh
visited with the families again this
morning as did
everybody probably standing here and we
uh
we heard from the israeli team that
is here and one of the things i wanted
to note was that the
israeli commander told us that the
teams that are out there working are
working fabulously together
there's a joint effort there's a
camaraderie
and everybody has the same goal and
that's to pull people out of there
he also added that uh the intensity
and the numbers will continue to
increase which i was very interested to
hear
um thirdly i want to make uh everybody
aware that there has been some
discussion about
uh why this happened and that is as
the mayor erica said and the governor
said
that's an issue for another day because
right now we have two issues
number one is to pull our family and
friends out of that rubble and reunite
them
number two is to support the families
but to the end uh
uh to the end uh with respect to the
information
we uh directed our staff to go ahead and
scan
every shred of documentation that the
town of serve site has
which includes going to our archive
storage sites
we've got boxes and we're sending those
boxes to a
printing scanning company and those
documents um
will be available for your review i know
you've seen some
um some documents already and again i
haven't had a chance to
watch the news because we're sort of in
the midst of this
disaster all of us i don't know i don't
know that anybody else has a chance to
watch the news either
but uh i i learn of stuff from you guys
and i'm able to follow up on it but most
recent are a couple disturbing
comments that i saw regarding
minutes board minutes at the champlain
south towers with respect to
some of our officials in town but be
that as it may we will get to the bottom
of it
last comment i want to make is late last
night i had
toured and this is on the personal side
i had toured the
site as i normally do usually i'm there
three times a day in the morning in the
afternoon
evening and i came across a little girl
and she's about 11 or 12 years old and i
had seen this little girl before and i
know
because she was with her mom and we had
talked
and i she had been with her dad i'm not
quite sure but she
one of her parents was in that building
at the time of the collapse and the
other parent lives a couple buildings
away
and she told me she goes back and forth
when i came across her she was sitting
in a chair
by herself with nobody around her
looking at her phone and i knelt down
and i asked her i said so what are you
doing
are you okay and she said yes and she
said something and
and what she was telling me i never i it
was it was a jewish prayer
but she was reading a jewish prayer to
herself
sitting at the site by where one of her
parents
presumably is
and that really brought it home to me
that
and she was just she wasn't crying
she was just lost she didn't know
what to do what to say
who to talk to and i was looking for her
this morning at that family meeting and
i didn't see her but i am going to find
her
and i'm going to tell her that we're all
here for her
and we're going to do the best we can to
bring out that parent
so anyway it's horrific this is
disturbing
but that is just a tiny tiny example
of the impact that this collapse has had
thank you mayor now miami-dade
commissioner chairman we'll save
these
mayor that story is uh
the story of so many that are in this
situation right now
the families we met with the mayor and i
this morning
the pain in their face their expressions
it's not unlike anything i've seen
before
it is it is very difficult
to know that your loved one could still
be alive
and have the hope to believe that
and at the same time
just sit there and wait for that
information to get to you
that's got to be one of the most
difficult things that anybody could
endure
and these people are doing it now as
governor said
100 hours as this took place
but the hope is there because the very
best team in the world
started early because they were
they are part of this community disorder
one
and many have come as a cfo stated
to come and help many more still could
come
as needed so this community
is blessed these people are blessed that
we have the kind of people
that know what they're doing they're the
very best at what they do
and they're doing it non-stop rain
whatever comes in the way they don't
stop and they'll continue
so it is about them
that is who this is about and
we pray for them we're constantly having
hope
and we're begging god for that hope
for them and that ladies and gentlemen
is what my colleagues and i have been
doing here
making sure that whatever is needed on
my behalf
has done so our mission doesn't not here
right now
it's just helping but it will come later
when we have to deal with the problems
of how this happened
and how we can make sure that this never
happens again
and that is where we're at it does
at this point
is
good afternoon uh we actively continue
our search and rescue operations
we have all florida task force teams on
site
uh still operating throughout our
12-hour operational periods
a very very challenging very difficult
situation
but we keep going okay looking searching
for any opportunity i have my assistant
of operations to come up just to speak
in a little more detail on what we're
covering
thank you chief all right so just a
recap from uh yesterday versus today and
what we're looking for
uh later on today so as the operations
continue
uh we had personnel utilizing uh bucket
brigade including the heavy machinery to
start removing some of the debris
this afternoon we'll be switching
positions as a result that most of the
individuals
have come up upon larger concrete areas
that now require heavy machinery during
that
process of the uh de-layering we did
find the tenth victim as the
honorable mayor had mentioned that
person was
processed and removed from the pile and
operations continued
again the operations continue in the
search and rescue mode
there's a there's a misunderstanding in
regarding that everyone believes that
the the search and rescue operation
should
cease after a specific time and and
that's far from the truth
in the end there's numerous variables
and facts it's not based on opinions
it's not based on time it's not based on
you know a specific area you just happen
to see on tv that went down
it's based on variables and facts in
conjunction with that
we have to consider all options then
and only then we take all that
information and we make a collective uh
decision but it's not going to be from
an office it's not going to be from a
television
it's not going to be from an individual
that's down the street it's going to be
made
collectively with the incident commander
and and
from there on before thank you
thank you assistant chief miami-dade
fire rescue
erica
is
is
yes
thank you and we're going to open up
your questions again please raise your
hand and be selected
right here i have two questions
for fire what do you say to people who
are
watching this at home and saying that
the search and rescue is going too slow
and then my second question is for mayor
louise cava
and the debriefs that you're having with
family what are the conversations like
and what are you telling them
uh okay so the first question regards
the fire that
the belief that the operations are going
too slow uh this discussion came up
during the
family assistance center it's one of the
questions that was brought up
to the by the family and this was uh you
know addressed
by us and again seconded by the israeli
team that was there
folks what we're dealing with is a
situation that
you know includes complexity and i know
that we utilized the words before
however the situation at hand is we're
not lifting
you know floor by floor we're talking
about pulverized concrete we're talking
about steel
every time there's an action there's a
reaction as it
as yesterday is a perfect example now we
have family members at the site
to basically see exactly what we've done
this is you know this is unconventional
especially so early in the stages
however as the individuals continue to
work
feverishly with urgency they witnessed a
rescuer tumbled 25 feet
down the mound that is the perfect
example of the situation that we're
dealing with
this was again it was witnessed by the
family members themselves
at the site so again it's not an issue
of
we could just attach a couple of uh
cords to a
concrete boulder and lift it and call it
a day we're digging through again
rubbles of
concrete the size of basketballs the
size of a
baseballs and then and only then in
combination with the the safety of the
personnel
and of course you know considering you
know the
the victims themselves it's going to
take time it's not going to happen
overnight
it's a 12 story building it's going to
take some time
to follow up with the part of the
question having to do with what is
discussed at the family briefings
that's what's discussed um assistant
chief of the
jabala has gone through in
extreme detail the map of the mound
it's marked out the grids explains
exactly
what's being done in each part of the
grid
after all of the technical questions are
answered
we talk about dna we talk about how the
dna match is going to be made
we talk about communicating with family
members
who will be the next of kin how will
they be contacted
uh who will be next to learn about it
how will it be
opened up for public uh knowledge uh
and we talk about their their questions
about
is enough being done and they have seen
firsthand what is being done and they
see
that everything has been done that can
be done and that
they recognize the full danger that
these
uh first responders are exposing
themselves to
and and what it has taken for them to
get to this point
families because of the process we've
gone through
are coming to their own conclusions some
are
feeling more hopeful some less hopeful
because we do not have definitive
answers we give them the facts
we take them to the site we show them
the operation
we show them where the pancake is we
show them
where the tunnel is we show them where
the dogs are
are running up and uh identifying
something that is
that is then going to be explored they
have seen the operation
they understand now how it works and
they are preparing themselves
for news one way or the other all right
one second we have a question are there
unidentified victims
is this an issue of dna for
communicating with
your friends
so we tell you the difference
we tell you when a person is identified
and we tell you when we can identify it
to you
which is after the next of kin have been
notified
you repeat
they're handling the homicide
investigation so they can answer
them in terms of the two unidentified
what was your question in terms of
question-wise on the unidentified
victims
is it an issue of dna that you don't
have or is it an issue that
you haven't been able to communicate
with your family
there's multiple variables when you're
dealing with this
it depends on the condition of the
family member that's recovered
we have crime scene and medical examiner
personnel
on scene with our firefighters when when
a family member is recovered
if it's possible we do a rapid dna test
and then immediately goes to the lab and
we expedite that component
once we have a positive match we in a
very sensitive and personal manner we
make contact with the nexus kin
if there's a component where we cannot
get rapid dna
the medical examiner will collect the
family member
and that process will happen at the
medical examiner's office
once that family member is identified
then that process
will happen we'll notify mexican same
way that's how we do and we do it all
with uh respect and integrity it's very
emotional
this whole process has been emotional
and that's why i call it family member
because what we've gone through here
i think we're all family now
[Music]
one moment let me just answer what was
that ma'am
we once we make that's why you see when
we say
we have uh lost 10 and there's nine
identified
that's because that process is going on
you know
when it comes to the part that it is a
family member that we're unable to
identify at that moment the medical
examiner will assist
that with that process and that'll come
along and obviously that'll affect the
numbers as we move along that's why
all these numbers that we're given are
right now subject to change we're
dealing with uh
with a very terrible situation here
that's why
we we have to be very always keep
mindful
of our family members that are listening
and watching right now
sir yes i'm sorry
you can just please talk about some of
the facts and variables you're gathering
that may be
providing you some hope all right so in
regards to some of the facts and
variables that uh
the operations and every operational
period that we hit upon
as we continue to de-layer just as we
mentioned to the families at the family
uh assistance center um we have
what we utilize is called sonars
listening devices
okay in addition to that some of the
facts that we have or some of the
variables are the uh the sizes
of the void spaces there's certain areas
that we have not gotten to but we've
been able to place cameras that
seem to have large enough spaces voids
that occupants may still be in there
again it's
it's in regards to the actual spaces not
to say that we've seen anybody down
there but we haven't gotten
to the very bottom in regards to the
sound so that there's no
misunderstanding
it's not sounds of uh you know people
talking or yelling out
as i've mentioned to the families it
could be a tap it could be a scratch
it may be nothing more than some of the
metal that's contorting
but at the end as i've said before all
variables
all facts have to be made before we make
a decision to move to the next phase
and i can tell you that it's not based
on one little section
because it was completely destroyed i
have to look at the entire pile
as 100 percent you know confirmed
in regards that we need to go to the
next uh phase and again i gotta re
uh you know we mentioned the fact that
we're just not there yet
we're just not there
what timeline
this is what's so amazing the work
that's being done not only by our fire
personnel but our homicide detective our
crime scene personnel
that and our medical examiner our rabbis
who are there
also on the scene that are helping us
when we are able to collect
it's called rapid dna when we we have a
family member where
they are eligible to go through the
rapid dna process
the moment that sample is taken that
detective that analyst will run directly
to the family unification center where
it's entered into a system
for for we so we can have the match with
the standards that we took
from family members then there's a
second protocol at the lab it's verified
because we cannot have
a partial it has to be a hundred percent
because we cannot re-victimize
our family members and give them wrong
information
typically what we've been seeing has
been within a day when we're able to get
the rapid dna component when the dna has
to be done from the medical examiner
they do it as fast as they can and then
that notification is made
but that's pretty much how the process
is and we do it as fast as we can and as
accurate and correctly as we can final
question
is
foreign
foreign
final question right the here
not just those here but to those around
florida who asked
in the face of published reports
suggesting that at least
potential big signals about problems
with this complex reserve side
and
how can people have confidence in the
process going forward
given that what at least initially
appears may have been simple
let me say from the county's perspective
the buildings that are under our
jurisdiction
are being reviewed we have on on site
we're going through every
building that that has been reviewed to
make sure that every
problem that's been identified is
pursued i feel confident that it has
been we have a very very rigorous
uh building department uh and we stand
ready to assist our cities just like
uh is happening in surfside to do that
deep dog and not only that
but immediately to make any changes that
we can
to make this process more robust in the
future
that's your question
yeah well no i did i didn't and that's
why you know because i'm
here sort of in the news rather than
watching it but
the bottom line is is you know my
commitment is
we're going to take everything we have
boxes digitally
get it scanned and get it up on the web
website it is what it is
we're going to let you guys sort of uh
review it and
we'll address it as it you know as it
comes but like i said
i think all of us agree that the number
one priority today is to
rescue people out of that rubble number
two is to support the families and then
we'll get to that
but just know that that is in the works
and we will be 100 percent transparent
good job and for creole translation even
more
i just want to acknowledge that we've
been joined by our agriculture
commissioner nikki
and by the way we want to thank all of
you for the news the way you're putting
it
on behalf of the mayor my colleagues
thank you so much
for the what you're doing
is
foreign
all right